we begin with those massive wildfires
that have made this one of the most
destructive summers in the West 89 large
fires in 13 states have burned more than
3/4 of a million acres forcing tens of
thousands of people to flee to safety
one of the biggest is a fast-moving
blaze north of Sacramento California six
other major fires are burning across the
state all fueled by high winds dry
conditions and triple digit temperatures
at least two people have been killed
almost 40,000 people have been forced to
flee their homes as the fire rapidly
spreads 500 buildings have been
destroyed and nearly 5,000 homes
threatened Carter Evans is in hard-hit
Redding California with the latest
Carter good morning good morning people
living in this neighborhood really had
very little time to escape when the fire
blew through here witnesses say it was
ferocious it wiped out just about
everything you can see home after home
after home just burned to the ground
it's like a war zone it's just like like
a bomb just hit hit each house and just
exploded
flames approaching the city of Redding
have scorched home
prompted mass evacuations and reduced an
entire neighborhood to ash and rubble
the car fire was started Monday by a
broken-down vehicle but he topping 100
degrees bone-dry conditions and vicious
wind gusts and embers flying across the
Sacramento River into reading overnight
Thursday and what began as a small
wildfire has now erupted into a living
hell ski there was fire everywhere on
both sides of the roads there's houses
coming down houses that were already
down to me it kind of looked like
apocalyptic horror film it was crazy
we're not getting any break from the
weather for at least the next five days
Cal Fire division chief Greg Bertelli
tells us his team is preparing for the
worst as the fire which now covers
48,000 acres rages on to fight fire in
rugged country we're used to doing that
but when it blows into a whole community
or a city it's a whole different
elements at least three people are
missing is the flames spread to Redding
children and their great grandmother and
so far two people have died a Redding
firefighter and a bulldozer operator
when Chris Corona returned to his family
home this was all that's left this is my
house since I was born
what's it like to see it now ruff
you know this fire was so hot you can
barely even tell that this was a home
behind me here you can make out the
washer and dryer here but that's about
it
it was these gusty winds and triple
digit temperatures that have been
fueling this fire
the winds are calming down a little bit
so that is some good news but the
temperatures are expected to remain over
100 degrees for the next week Michelle
no let-up Carter Evans in Redding
California thank you